ladies and gentlemen please give it up  for mr. Janet Jackson Janet Jackson  receives the music icon award at out  magazines out 100 celebration gala  [Music]  beautiful he was exclusively inside the  annual bash presented by Lexus  celebrating the LGBTQ community before  receiving her award Janet's stunned on  the red carpet rocking an edgy jumpsuit  complete with gloves and a cape the  proud mama took the stage to receive her  big honour she opened up about the  importance of love and inclusivity my  heart says so much of today's public  discourse is ugly so much prejudice so  much bullying so much narrow-minded  bigotry but then my heart says look at  you people here tonight there's you're  so loving so giving so willing to let  the world know that differences don't  matter and in drew Janet fashion she  ended her speech with a nod to one of  her most classic hits everywhere I go  [Applause]  every smile I see  I know you were there smiling back at me  [Music]